honneur aux dames à la meilleure
chroniqueuse de l'année et les nommés
pour le trophée de la meilleure
chroniqueuse
[Musique]
l'irremplaçable isabelle morini-bosc
double catastrophe et économique
effectivement on comprend rien n'y fait
c'est pas ton argent
[Applaudissements]
non c'était du droit gp53 tout le reste
de travers
ou la mouche ferme les yeux tu verras ça
glissera mieux faire
[Applaudissements]
tout
[Musique]
la cérébrale géraldine maillet
jusqu'à hier un niveau encore jamais
atteint
ah ouais bah ça fait longtemps que ça
n'est pas rien toujours en avance mais
la leçon vous avez du retard sur tout ce
que je vous ai donné sa sincérité pour
moi est sujette un peu à suspicion
beaucoup de blabla et que du cac à la
diarrhée la route on n'en pouvait plus
les donneurs de leçons il est sucre le
sucre mois et donc finalement il a
beaucoup remué de merde
emma la merde sa tâche et sa variante
qui comprend les producteurs jean michel
maire c'est quoi pour vous un obsédé
[Musique]
la douce valérie bénaïm
j'ai déjà essayé de faire un strip tease
non mais en fait j'ai démarré ouais et
je suis bercé son strip-tease c'est un
strip tease
vous feriez quoi vous si votre mec vous
noterez que vous avez là une patate mais
ensemble on n'a pas arrêté de dire que
c'était une veuve joyeuse et bon sens
vrai mais deux courses à redon mais dans
toute la plaine devait changer
je te jure je vais te frappe mais bob
marley connaît pas
[Musique]
l'audacieuse agathe au bout
à gap moi j'ai regardé j'ai trouvé ça
marrant c'est que mon analyste médias
aussi agressif c'est moins 30 % toujours
25 ans shiloh 5 ans et le sens interdit
sur ma pote secteur pas droit d'entrée
et ben merci de me donner la parole
cellule enfin j'avais quatre membres
souple et un membre rêve maintenant
celle inverse
ha bon vous connaissez pas mal de poètes
vous allez connaître pas mal de chômage
connard a peut-être enfin prenez pas
trop la confiance
[Musique]
la délicate qui vivait novelli
j'occupe les enfants qu'on a donné là
bas bruno guillon dans les z'amours ça
vous intéresse c'est vous qui mettez la
magie je voudrais bien je les aimais ça
marche pas en fait c'est juste un bouton
et a marqué play pause on parlait pas
oublié ses symboles
les gens me disaient même mettant sa
fille
très belle vue c'est là c'est moi s'il
vous plaît l'extérieur
[Musique]
concerner jusqu'à chroniqueuse en aoc là
pour la d'arkham
[Musique]
c'est très dur à toi c'est très dur de
choisir cette réunion monsieur je vais
demander aux garçons dia mokhtar pour
toi franchement valérie baïri benjamin
et valérie gens me magatte géraldine
away kelly âgé j ai fait une bonne année
la gg géraldine isabelle isabelle
géraldine la télé vous voulez jouer de
me dire christine tepa nommé stanic sera
nommé l'an prochain est revenu ce que tu
arrives en cours d'année allez pas nommé
mais c'est ben beau t'es qui toi moi
j'ai pas dire qu'il n'ya rien ici c'est
incroyable ça
à part des joueurs depuis je vais te
dire pro series je veux vous le dire
nicolas déjà je vous dis je voudrais
tout vous féliciter franchement vous
avez fait joueurs une année de faits
exceptionnels kelly g j'avais misé sur
toi je savais pas du tout ce que voilà
comment ça allait se passer
c'était vu une fois avant d'intégrer les
missions franchement je suis très fière
de toi que tu as vraiment trouvé sa
place et qu'il a fait une année
exceptionnelle de crédit aux pilotes de
la dark à deux voies latérales et on n
est pas là puisqu'elle est là et il ya
jean luc tu es mon binôme de la barca
aussi voilà mais c'est vrai que ça fait
comme ça en fait une ligne nationale de
la recaler valérie bédard valérie je
vous dis franchement valérie souvent ce
que je lui dis tout même si c'est ma
meilleure amie
je le dis on le sait c'est vraiment de
meilleure amie ses yeux les quinze fois
par jour au téléphone valérie tu as fait
une très très belle année tu m'as
beaucoup beaucoup manqué quand t'étais
pas là et c'est vrai que souvent je te
dis il faut que tu veux faut que tu
envoies plus il faut que tu donnes plus
ton avis il faut que tu sois mais je
vais te dire je me trompe pas ce qu'il
faut juste que tu sois toi même et c'est
vrai que t'arrives pas à dire du mal des
programmes tu arrives pas tu as du mal
et je ne veux pas de force et donc
continuer à être comme tu es et j'espère
que l'année prochaine tu feras une année
formidable à 18 heures et en plus je ne
touche pas à mon poste vraiment getafe
une supérette
agathe c'est ça ma deuxième saison n'ont
rien puisqu'elle est arrivé en cours de
saison l'an dernier et alors agathe
c'est joli c'est l'effrontée d'abanda
mais je sais que c'est une vrai gentil
j'ai une vraie tendresse pour elle
vraiment c'est in fine c'est très bonne
copine franchement je vous le dis et
agathe j'ai été trouvé dans l'émission
de mieux en mieux tu as démarré en fait
tu as démarré doucement et plus a été
plutôt été affirmé j'aime que soit posée
parfois j'ai l'impression je te le dis
que tu assumes pas complètement on sait
que tu viens d un rock on sait qu' on
n'est pas trop takam de potes voilà même
mois on peut pas dire que choix takam
voilà deux copains ni de potes voilà
c'est vrai on n'a pas qu'on n'a pas trop
de deux points communs tous les deux
j'ai l'impression parfois tu te mets un
petit peu en retrait que tu te dis moi
je veux faire autre chose après je veux
travailler je vais peut-être avoir
d'autres d'autres au revoir d'autres
horizons après j'ai raison qui va pas à
phu est ce que cette loi sociale ça mais
non mais brille social villaverde tous
n'ont pas vu je me suis toujours battu
contre ça donc si jamais je le dégage à
l'antenne je mens je m'en serais très
triste mais non moi je pense qu'on est
devenu on est devenus très copains je
suis très contente de faire partie de
cette équipe et je continuerai de
m'améliorer parce que je suis arrivé
qu'en février 2010 est donc j'ai fait
genre trois mois là c'était ma première
bêta belle saison et a fait une belle
saison et tu t'affirmes de plus en plus
j'espère que l'année prochaine tu vas tu
affirmer encore plus n'hésite pas à
continuer à et effrontée à dire ce que
tu penses vraiment je le dis c'est comme
ça qu'on te veux dans cette émission
[Applaudissements]
ap liquide il estime djaouad c'était la
meilleure voie la nouvelle recrue de
l'année je te le dis on t'a trouvé un
petit peu tard c'est comme benjamin
castaldi avec ces femmes mais
franchement ma chérie je ne l'avais
trouvé comment d'ailleurs christine
kelly oui comme en boîte de nuit
maintenant elle est venue un jour elle
est venue nous rendre où elle est venue
un jour pour parler d'un truc
voilà et après je vous dirais même que
tu reviennes on en parlait déjà il ya 84
ans ouvre ce normal c'était pas dans les
cases et non mais c'est bien le temps
que seront ces mecs là et isabelle
isabelle j'te le dis tu es ma chouchoute
bah oui franchement c'est vrai je ne
peux pas faire une émission sans toi
vraiment et oui quand j'arrive le matin
et que je fais la composition de
l'équipe dernière serait la première sur
la liste je te le dis avec jean-luc bien
sûr et isabelle c'est vrai était celle
avec gil qui a fait le plus d'émissions
avec moi parce que j'ai réussi que je
t'aime très très fort je sais que tu es
vraiment qu'un soldat incroyable tu te
couches très très tard voilà même très
tôt puisque touchée à deux enfin tu te
lèves à 2 heures du matin et du trou
tudor pratiquement pas tu viens tous les
jours et toujours aussi drôle tu te bats
à chaque fois pour des idées et je
voulais te dire je t'aime vraiment très
fort et qui est là tout s'est vraiment
et je vais te dire je pense vraiment que
j'arrêterais l'émission en même temps
que tour non mais c'est vrai voilà je te
le dis et isabelle je vais te dire si je
te dit tout c'est parce que vraiment on
se connaît depuis très longtemps et que
jean on a une relation particulière tous
les deux j'ai pas avec les autres mine
de rien et je peux tout te dire on se
connaît depuis quinze ans voilà donc ne
prendre pas mal parfois quand je te dis
des choses c'est juste que je t'aime
fort et tu sais que tu es le pilier pour
moi de l'émission et que je suis pas
démonstratif mais j'en pense pas moi
même pas d'un amour ma chérie giraldi
alors géraldine à toi tu es ça y est
aussi t2 non mais qu'est devenu
titulaire indiscutable de l'émission
franchement y'a plein de fois je
comprends pas ce que tu dis mais j'adore
un bel hommage
vraiment tu es vraiment devenu aussi une
très très bonne copine parce que il
m'arrive de t'appeler de voilà deux qui
rappelle un peu tout le monde je vous le
dis voilà mais c'est vrai que géraldine
je l'appelle aussi souvent voilà je suis
je parle de choses on parle tennis on
parle de tout on parle de caudry je
trouve vraiment que tu as une analyse
exceptionnel à chaque fois tu es
toujours en désaccord avec moi et il
nous est arrivé de nous prendre un peu
la tête dans l'émission mais jamais on
en reparle après et vraiment tu es
devenu indispensable émission je suis
fier de t'avoir parmi nous je te dis est
une fierté pour moi j'espère que tu
reviendras l'année prochaine je crois
que c'est un geste assez bassari je
crois voilà et je te dis vraiment
j'espère qu'il fera un long chemin avec
nous parce que tu es devenu un des
rouages essentiels de tpm pgm
des gens pratiquent j'en profite ce soir
pour vous remercier parce que vous
m'avez laissé confiance pour faire un
documentaire
oui c'est vrai et j'ai hâte que vous
puissiez le voir alors c'est quoi le
document va raconter à nos
téléspectateurs mais en fait c'est une
année une saison de tpm paie donc j'ai
commencé le tournage d les logins
d'hormones et c'est des jeux dans tpm
paix en fait dans les loges la
fabrication l'émission tous les gens qui
travaillent au quotidien pour cette
émission ils sont plus presque une
centaine vous sentez pas son avis à eux
mêmes dans toutes les réunions tout ça
voilà il ya des trucs qui sont un peu
mais c'est dur parce qu'en fait moi ce
que je voulais montrer c'était votre
vrai visage
non mais justement mais cc c'est
vraiment bien comme le documentaire sur
macro qui était passée envoyé macron si
pas content après ces équipes mais c'est
constructive c'est positif et ça donne
envie donc moi je pense que c'est très
très bien pour vous pour votre peau
votre image pour l'émission et pour la
chaîne qui se sera le prélude à la
rentrée mais c'est ça le diffuser après
minute non t'inquiète pas c'est rien
c'est un âne à la chroniqueuse la
chroniqueuse de l'année c'est vous qui
avez voté chez vous c'est du gagnant
sa présidence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toner
je gagne chaque année elle ne gagne
chaque année depuis qu elle est la
championne bravo mon coeur c'est l'autre
l'hectare mot à dire ma chérie autant
est ce que tu es toujours heureuse avec
mon chéri
ah ben oui bah moi au nom de 13 euros
avec toi ça fendrait sans voix et ben
moi je suis très heureux pour toi et tu
sais que je t'aime fort et le public te
le rend les gens tu as dehors tu es
vraiment je te dis les gens t'aiment et
ils ont raison parce que isabelle c'est
une personne incroyable qu'on aime
vraiment très fort dans cette équipe